Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Wir machen heute was richtig Leckeres zum Mittag- oder Abendessen.
In unserem Fall zum Iftar, also zum sogenannten Fastenbrechen. Wir sind ja noch mitten im Ramadan.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht wir machen einfach Kebab aus dem Ofen, bzw. Hackbällchen mit Kartoffeln und Tomatensoße aus dem Backofen.
Ich fange direkt an und schreibe euch wie immer die ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Infobox.
[Hamza] Kannst du einmal so machen Kiki?
[Kiki] So?
[Hamza] Ja, nochmal!
[Kiki] Warum?
[Hamza] Nochmal!
[Hamza] Das sieht süß aus! *lacht*
[Kiki] Hä? Oh mein Gott, wie verwirrend! Okay.
Wir fangen jetzt direkt an.
Jetzt bin ich voll ausm Konzept wegen dir, mach mal 'nen Cut eben!
[Hamza] Biep!
Mein Hackfleisch, das ist vom Rind übrigens und das ist sehr, sehr, sehr fettarm
aber das braucht ihr für dieses Rezept gar nicht.
Mein Metzger hatte jetzt nichts anderes da, deswegen hab ich's genommen.
Ich werde jetzt aber auch direkt schon ein bisschen Olivenöl hinzufügen.
Ihr könnt halt auch Fleisch nehmen, das schon ein bisschen Fettanteil hat.
Aber es sollte auch nicht zu fettig sein, denn sonst schwimmt das ganze Fett später nach dem Backen überall rum.
Ich mache jetzt weiter und werde da meine Zwiebel reinreiben
und anschließend noch Petersilie fein hacken und dazugeben.
Ich hab außerdem noch Paniermehl und ein Ei dazugegeben.
Bevor ich das knete kommen jetzt noch die Gewürze mit dazu.
Natürlich Salz und Pfeffer, der Klassiker.
Und dann könnt ihr einfach schauen, was ihr am liebsten mögt.
Bei mir kommen auch noch 3 weitere Klassiker hinein,
nämlich Kreuzkümmel, das mag ich total gerne im Fleisch und da kommt bei mir auch immer ganz viel rein.
Dann nehme ich noch Paprikapulver edelsüß und Pul Biber,
das sind quasi ich sag mal türkische, scharfe Paprikaflocken.
Davon mache ich dann nicht soo viel rein weil wir mögen's nicht ganz so scharf.
Also wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr auch ein bisschen reinhauen davon.
Ich hab jetzt die Hackfleischmasse einfach mit den Händen geknetet, das dauert auch nur 3-4min.
Und jetzt einmal alles zu kleinen Bällchen formen.
Nehmt euch einfach einen Esslöffel oder ein bisschen weniger als einen Esslöffel und dann fleißig formen!
Ihr könnt euch die Hände übrigens zwischendurch immer nass machen, dann lässt sich das besser formen.
Und ich würde sagen: Hamza, du kannst den Zeitraffer anmachen weil das dauert hier jetzt ein paar Minuten.
[Hamza] Jackpot!
Ich lege die Bällchen dann direkt auf mein Backblech.
So, die Hackfleischbällchen habe ich jetzt hier direkt auf mein Backblech gegeben
und jetzt mache ich da noch Kartoffeln mit dazu.
Eigentlich könntet ihr jetzt alles an Gemüse nehmen, was ihr mögt und was ihr noch da habt.
Zucchini z.B. oder Paprika oder Möhren.. alles, was ihr wollt!
Ich bleibe jetzt bei der klassischen Variante: Kartoffeln und Hackfleisch.
Und dafür die Kartoffeln einmal schälen - wo habe ich meinen Schäler? Aha!
Ich hab nämlich grad schon angefangen. Also ich schäle die jetzt
und dann werde ich sie mit meinem Wellenschneider klein schneiden.
Die gebe ich jetzt auch roh mit dazu weil ich spare mir jetzt die Arbeit, das vorher zu garen.
Das könnt ihr auch ganz einfach indem ihr die Kartoffeln so klein schneidet,
dass sie ungefähr halb so groß sind wie die Hackfleischbällchen.
Was wäre ein Ofengericht ohne eine richtig leckere Soße?
Und die geht jetzt auch super, super schnell, ihr braucht ganz wenige Zutaten.
Ich stehe jetzt hier schon am Herd, habe hier Sonnenblumenöl in meine Pfanne gegeben.
Einmal hier schön erwärmen und dann wird Paprika- und Tomatenmark darin richtig schön angeröstet.
Das dauert wirklich nur so 20-30sek.
*Lüftung bläst*
Tschuldigung!
Und danach löschen wir das Ganze ab mit Wasser und Sahne.
Ihr könnt statt Sahne auch ruhig diese fettreduzierte Sahne nehmen.
Und das Ganze mit Gemüsebrühe würzen, das war's!
Und jetzt einmal in den Backofen. Der muss vorgeheizt sein, das ist ganz wichtig.
Ich heize ihn schön vor auf 220° (also richtig schön heiß) Ober- und Unterhitze.
Und dann braucht das Ganze so ca. 40min.
Ihr könnt ja auch mal in die Kartoffeln reinschauen
aber nach 40min sind die 100%-ig gar und das Fleisch sowieso.
Ich persönlich serviere dazu noch Reis.
Das mag euch vielleicht komisch vorkommen: Kartoffeln und Reis?
Aber irgendwie ist das auch relativ normal in unserer Essenskultur, bei uns zumindest.
Ihr könnt dazu aber auch einfach nur einen Salat servieren, das ist auch super lecker.
Wir mögen's auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr, sehr gerne
und ich würde sagen ich verabschiede mich einfach an der Stelle schonmal bei euch.
Taste Test können wir sehr gerne dranhängen, machen wir ja auf Instagram aktuell.
Können wir sehr gerne dranhängen, ich hoffe wir vergessen's wieder nicht.
[Kiki] Ne, Hamza?
[Hamza] Ich hoffe!
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch einen guten Appetit
und hinterlasst mir gerne einen Kommentar wenn ihr das leckere Rezept mal ausprobiert habt.
So, bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss, eure Kiki!